.
Ich habe Lust, reinzuspringen.
- Aber es ist sicher sehr kalt.
Das ist egal.
Auf der Ferieninsel Mallorca.
Aufpassen, Ronaldo.
Es ist sehr kalt.
Gewaltig, nicht wahr?
Schau, die Steine dort unten.
Ja.
- Mega.
Für Gabor und Otmar soll
die Insel zur neuen Heimat werden.
Es ist so schön hier.
- Mhm.
Frisch vermählt starten Isabelle
und Steff Felix ins grosse Abenteuer.
Bye-bye, Villa am Vierwaldstättersee,
ab in die Einsamkeit Islands.
Dort übernehmen sie eine Gäste-Lodge
und sie wollen Tiny-Häuser bauen.
Vor der Abreise gibt's aber
schlechte Nachrichten vom Zimmermann.
Vor drei bzw. vier Tagen
erhielten wir eine Absage.
Er hat das Baumaterial aus Russland
nicht erhalten.- Mhm.
Er hat kein Holz
und daher ist das Projekt für ihn
momentan nicht durchführbar.
Kann der neue Zimmermann aushelfen?
Herzlich willkommen
in Ostermundigen.
Bei Tscharners sind alle
durch und durch Fans der USA.
* Jauchzer *
Sie tauschen
den Swimmingpool im Rheintal
gegen das Meer in Florida ein.
Irgendwas schwimmt dort im Wasser.
Mit Immobilien wollen sie
künftig ihr Geld verdienen.
Unsere Geschäftsidee ist der Umbau
von nicht so tollen Häusern,
die jedoch Rohdiamanten sind.
Bereits in ihrem Besitz: dieses
Mobile Home - vorerst ihr Daheim.
Hier ist ja alles schmutzig.
- Was ist schmutzig?
Der Boden.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Gabor Balogh und Otmar Gemperli zieht
es auch in die Selbstständigkeit.
Als ich selbstständig war,
war ich viel zufriedener.
Auf Mallorca, ihrem Sehnsuchtsort,
übernehmen sie ein Restaurant.
(Frau) Hola, buenas, qué tal?
Hasta luego.
... bis ihr eure Wohnung habt.
Sie beziehen ein Zimmer bei
der bisherigen Inhaberin des Lokals.
Alles gut, tipptopp.
# Uf u dervo, yeah.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Verträumte Countrymusik *
Es ist früh am Morgen, und Familie
Tscharner ist bereits unterwegs.
Die Nacht war bitterkalt. Die Familie
hat die ganze Nacht gefroren.
4 °C nur.
Eine so kalte Oktobernacht gab es in
Florida seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr.
Kaum war es hell, sind sie
nach Tallahassee aufgebrochen.
Jetzt brauchen wir
zuerst einen Heizofen.
Ja, damit wir
nicht mehr frieren müssen.
Unserer ist der Sauberste.
Sind die Öfen wohl hier?
- Mhm.
Wir froren letzte Nacht
ein bisschen.
Die Gasheizung
ist leider ausgefallen.
Wir liessen morgens
nicht viel Zeit verstreichen
und fuhren gleich los.
Für die Kinder
war es zum Spielen zu kühl.
Nun brauchen wir einen Heizofen.
Jehle hat versucht, anzurufen.
- Oh.
Ihr Makler in der Schweiz
hat sich gemeldet.
Papa muss kurz telefonieren.
Die Interessenten
besichtigen zurzeit gerade das Haus.
Denn noch ist ihr Haus in der Schweiz
nicht verkauft.
Hallo, Marco.
Hier ist Mario. Hallo.
Wo sind die Kinder?
- Bei den Spielsachen.
Ruby?
Wir sind gerade bei Walmart,
weisst du.
Ich muss aufpassen,
dass sie nicht das Regal abräumt.
Ja, es wäre nicht schlecht, wenn
du noch etwas rausholen könntest.
Ein Grosseinkauf,
die Mädchen bei Laune halten
und gleichzeitig
das eigene Haus verkaufen -
die Eltern sind gefordert.
Okay. Danke schön.
Tschüss, einen schönen Tag, tschau.
Schau,
so einer würde richtig wärmen.
* Dynamische Musik *
Der Verkauf in der Schweiz
muss gelingen.
Dessen Erlös ist ein wichtiger Teil
ihres Startkapitals
in der neuen Heimat,
denn noch haben sie nur Auslagen.
Das hat nun doch 390 ¤ gekostet.
Das ist klar - wegen der Öfen.
- Mhm.
Nicht wahr?
- Dafür haben wir nun schön warm.
Auf dem Weg zurück
können sie aufatmen:
Der Verkauf gelingt.
Das Haus in der Schweiz
ist Geschichte,
die Zukunft kann beginnen.
Und doch:
Es schmerzt schon ein bisschen.
Wir wussten zwar, dass wir es
verkaufen, wenn wir auswandern,
damit wir ein neues Zuhause
für uns schaffen können,
aber wir geben das Haus mit einem
lachenden und weinenden Auge auf.
Es war wirklich
unser Traumhaus in der Schweiz,
aber nun suchen wir
unser Traumhaus in Florida.
Habt ihr diese Sachen wieder aus
dem Schrank rausgenommen?- Nein.
Ich räume die ganze Zeit auf.
- Ich habe alles weggeräumt.
Aua.
V.a. wegen der Kinder
wollen die Eltern bald
wieder ein richtiges Zuhause haben.
* Eines der Kinder schreit. *
- Ruby, hör auf!
Hörst du jetzt auf?
Für den Anfang ist es super hier
und wunderbar, um Ferien zu machen,
aber Lily Rose ist in einem Alter,
in dem sie gern
ein eigenes Zimmer hätte.
Sie braucht Zeit für sich, damit sie
mal etwas zeichnen kann oder so.
Daher freuen wir uns riesig.
Ist der wirklich fürs Wohnzimmer?
Es steht ja "indoor" darauf. Später
kann ich damit die Werkstatt heizen.
Füllst du ihn mit Petrol?
- Klar, ich fülle den Tank da unten.
Und hier ist dann ein Feuer?
Äh, ja.
(Lachend) Das ist doch logisch.
Nein, da unten ist nur
eine kleine Flamme, im Innern.
Keine Flip-Flops, kein Sonnenschirm,
sondern ein Petrolofen:
Familie Tscharners erster Kauf
im Sonnenstaat Florida -
damit haben sie nicht gerechnet.
Ah, jetzt brennt es.
Was habe ich ausgerechnet?
Er hat 7 Kilowatt.
Das ist so viel wie sechs
der kleinen Heizöfen zusammen.
Im Wohnzimmer soll es warm sein.
* Er lacht. *
Ja, er wärmt schön.
Letzter Morgen in der Schweiz:
Heute nehmen die Island-Auswanderer
Abschied von der Familie.
Ist schon Zucker drin?
- Ja, vier Löffel.
Was? Vier Löffel?
- Wenn's recht ist.
Isabelles Mutter hat die beiden
während der letzten Tage beherbergt.
Steff hat gute Neuigkeiten:
Er ist mit dem neuen Zimmermann
handelseinig geworden.
Wir erhielten
ein Okay aus Ostermundigen.
Sie würden das Projekt
sehr gern mit uns angehen.
Ich sagte spontan zu,
ohne Isa zu fragen.
Ich informierte Isa später darüber,
dass ich Ja gesagt habe.
Wir sind happy.
- Mhm.
Ein Berner Zimmermann also
wird in Island für Isabelle und Steff
Tiny-Häuser bauen.
Ihr seid sicher froh,
dass es endlich so weit ist.
Ja, schon.
- Ja, das schon.
Gemischte Gefühle?
- Ja, genau.
Richtig bewusst
wird es uns wahrscheinlich erst,
wenn wir auf der Fähre sind.
Zuerst fahren wir mit dem Auto los.
Erst wenn wir auf der Fähre sind
oder wenn wir ankommen,
wird uns richtig bewusst sein,
dass wir dort sind.
Auch Isabelles Schwester und Familie
wollen sie verabschieden.
Jetzt schauen wir, wie ihr ...
- ... euch verabschiedet.
Es ist nicht so einfach.
* Brummen der Kaffeemaschine *
Ich weiss nicht, wie es noch wird,
aber zurzeit
ist es schon etwas emotional.
Es tut mir schon ein bisschen weh.
Glücklicherweise
ist meine zweite Tochter noch hier.
Ja.
Die Überfahrt mit der Fähre
dauert drei Tage.
Einen halben Tag lang
sind wir auf den Färöern.
Dann fährt man weg und
entfernt sich langsam von Europa.
Die Reise schlägt Isabelle
schon jetzt auf den Magen.
Wird das bald besser?
Ja, man kann sich
etwas darauf einstellen.
Wenn man weiss, wie es ist,
stellt man sich schon darauf ein.
Vielleicht
wird es dann nicht so schlimm.
Wenn es wieder so ist
wie das letzte Mal, ist es halt so.
Dann liege ich halt wieder
zwei Tage lang in der Kajüte.
* Lachen, sanfte Klavierklänge *
Schon früh hat Isabelle
ihren Vater verloren.
Umso mehr hängt sie
an ihrer kleinen Familie:
der Tante, Schwester ...
... Mutter.
(Tränenerstickt) Mach's gut.
- Du auch.
Also, Tochter,
melde dich immer zwischendurch.
Ich höre von dir.
* Sanfte, melancholische Klänge *
Ihr besucht uns bald, nicht wahr?
Jetzt ist es endgültig.
- Tschüss zusammen.
* Sanfte, melancholische Klänge *
* Die Musik klingt aus. *
* Sanfte Musik
mit elfenhaftem Frauengesang *
* Schiffshorn *
Der Hafen Seydisfjördur
im Nordwesten von Island.
* Leise, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Nach drei langen Tagen auf See
kommen die Auswanderer
an einem kalten Mai-Morgen an.
Also, die Reise war ... ähm ...
Bis zu den Färöer-Inseln
war sie eigentlich super.
* Steff lacht. *
Und ab den Färöern ...
Na ja.
Wir hatten so hohen Wellengang,
dass ich ...
... froh war,
wenn ich liegen konnte.
Obwohl das auch nicht toll war.
Nun weisst du, dass du mir nie
eine Kreuzfahrt schenken musst.
(Lachend) Damit machst du mir
wirklich keine Freude.
Mit festem Boden unter den Rädern
geht die Fahrt
über den Fjardarheidi-Pass.
Island ist nach Grönland das
am dünnsten besiedelte Land Europas.
Die Distanzen sind weit.
Gibt es eine Einkaufsgelegenheit,
wird sie genutzt.
Wie diese Bäckerei in Egilsstadir -
auf halber Wegstrecke.
Hast du Geld dabei?
- Ja.
(Frau) Gódan daginn.
- Gódan daginn.- Daginn.
One of this.
- This one?- (Beide) Yes.
Und dann noch eins?
- Wie lange ist das wohl haltbar?
Where are you from?
- Switzerland.
Ja? I'm from Germany.
- Ah, from Germany?
Wir können auch deutsch sprechen.
- Ja, das ist einfacher.
Wir ziehen heute um.
- Echt? Wohin?
Vor dem Hengifoss gibt es eine
Liegenschaft mit zwei roten Häusern.
Ja.
- Diese haben wir übernommen.
Das ist ja cool.
Morgen ist unser Stammtisch.
Stammtisch?
- Ja, wir haben ...
Es ist ein Stammtisch
für Deutschsprachige,
also für Deutsche,
Österreicher und Schweizer.
Ne!
- Wenn ihr kommen mögt ...
Echt? Wo?
- Wenn wir eingeladen sind.
Ja, ja, ja.
Super, klasse.
- Tschüss.- Bis morgen.
Das war jetzt echt unglaublich.
Morgen Abend bereits ein ...
- ... Date.
Das war wirklich total süss.
Man fühlte sich gleich
total willkommen, nicht?- Mhm.
Es geht weiter, 30 km weiter
in die Abgeschiedenheit.
Gleich in Meeresnähe,
schön zentral gelegen,
ist die Zukunft von Gabor und Otmar.
Heute beginnen sie
mit dem Umbau des Restaurants.
Guten Morgen. Hallo.
- Guten Morgen.
Die beiden haben
eine Vereinbarung mit Corinna:
Schrittweise wird sie
das Restaurant an Otmar übergeben.
So kann sie sich langsam
von ihrem Geschäft verabschieden
und den Auswanderern auf dem Weg
in die Selbstständigkeit helfen.
Das ganze Inventar - die Möbel,
Pfannen bis zum Kaffeelöffel -,
alles wird bald ihnen gehören.
Die Gerümpelecke.
Die Pflanzen aber,
die wollen sie weghaben.
Das ist auch so
eine Art Kletterpflanze.
Corinna führte das Restaurant
jahrelang nach ihrem Gusto.
Jetzt ist es an Gabor und Otmar,
ihre Ideen zu verwirklichen.
Später gibt es hier
eine schöne Sitzlounge.
Gemütlich, mit zwei Pflanzen
und kleinen Tischchen,
um gemütlich zu verweilen.
Im Winter sieht natürlich
alles sehr dürr aus.
Aber das hier
ist im Sommer wieder schön.
Das nehme ich mit,
als Deko für meine Terrasse.
Ja, es ist ein Gummiboden.
Ja, danke.
* Dynamische Musik *
- Okay, das geht.
Prima.
Bei so viel Eifer kommt es
schnell zu Missverständnissen.
Die Pflanzen vorn nehme ich mit.
- Welche nimmst du mit?
Achtung.
- Ah, das wusste ich nicht, sorry.
Die hast du jetzt platt gedrückt.
- Welche?
Nein!
- Ne, ne, ne, nimm sie raus.
Warte kurz. Ich dachte,
das sei alles zum Entsorgen.
Nein, nicht alles.
- Nein, die anderen nehme ich ...
Das habe ich dreimal gesagt.
Die kommen auf meinen Balkon.
Sie ist kaputt.
Drei Wochen noch, und dann ist
Eröffnung. Otmar macht zügig weiter.
Corinna, die gerne
alles unter Kontrolle hat,
geht es plötzlich viel zu schnell
und viel zu chaotisch.
Falls noch etwas abgerissen
oder weggeschmissen werden soll,
sagt mir vorher Bescheid.
Aber das, was ich gemacht habe,
haben wir besprochen.- Ja.
Aber wir hatten ja besprochen, dass
du hinten anfängst und dann ...
Ja, aber bis ihr wiederkommt,
mache ich einfach weiter.
Noch ein Missverständnis.
Sag mir einfach Bescheid,
was du gerade vorhast.
Mhm.- Damit ich weiss,
was gerade passiert.
Immerhin: Eine Familie,
die per Zufall vorbeikommt,
will das Geländer übernehmen.
(Corinna, Spanisch)
Otmar
kann es nicht schnell genug gehen.
Wenn man etwas vorhat,
muss man vorwärtsmachen.
Wir haben einen Plan,
was wir realisieren wollen,
und diesen Plan verfolgen wir.
Wir müssen Gas geben,
sonst schaffen wir das nicht.
Island ist bekannt für
seine spektakulären Landschaften.
Ein Touristenmagnet
sind die Wasserfälle.
Der Hengifoss-Wasserfall
ist nur wenige Kilometer entfernt
von Isabelle und Steffs
neuem Zuhause.
* Verträumte Musik
mit elfenhaftem Frauengesang *
Ja, jetzt sind wir zu Hause.
Hengifosslodge
heisst denn auch ihr Anwesen.
Vor gut einem halben Jahr
haben sie es gekauft.
Jetzt haben wir ganz viele
Schlüssel. Hier sind ein paar.
Ja! Juhu.
So ...
So.
Ich mache mal Licht.
* Beide lachen. *
Ich muss kurz ankommen.
Cool.
Okay?
Mal sehen ...
In der Schweiz am Vierwaldstättersee
besassen sie ein grossräumiges Haus.
Hier haben wir
nur die Hälfte der Fläche,
aber es ist mehr unser Ding.
Es ist einfach ...
Es ist heimeliger.
- Es hat mehr Herz.
Ja, es ist wirklich ...
Ja, es hat mehr Herz.
Wenn ich hier im Bett liege ...
Schau, das ist auch kaputt.
- Ist das meine Seite?
Das ist auch kaputt.
Ob das deine Seite ist?
Ich muss schauen,
welche Seite ich will.
Es sind beide gut.
Die dort ist kälter.
- Ja, dann bist du dort.
Ich wusste es.
Nein, die ist gut.
Neben ihrem Wohnhaus, dem Hús,
steht ein weiteres Gebäude:
das Ferienhaus mit drei
bereits eingerichteten Apartments.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Trotz der Freude über das neue Leben
schmerzt Isabelle
der Abschied noch immer.
Super.
(Mutter) Das hat gut geklappt, was?
- Ja, alles prima.
Ist bei euch auch alles in Ordnung?
Ja, bei uns ist alles in Ordnung.
- Okay.
Also, gut, dann ...
- Wir hören uns.
Grüss Steff.
- Ja, das mache ich.
Bis bald, tschüss.
Tschüss, hey.
- Tschüss, hey.
Ja ...
Es ist schon schwierig.
Es tut schon noch weh.
Aber, ähm ... Ja.
Zum Glück gibt es Handys.
Man kann ja jederzeit anrufen.
Aber es wird sicher noch
ein paarmal wehtun,
bis es sich etwas gesetzt hat.
Und ...
Ja.
Immerhin:
Ihr Zuhause ist bereits heimelig.
Sie haben
die ganze Einrichtung mitgekauft.
Ich hoffe, sie sind gar. Koste mal.
Tipptopp gar.
Auf unser Hús.
- Aufs Hús.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl.
* Sanfte, verträumte Musik *
Weiter.- Aber hier und dort
sind noch welche.
Die dienen wohl als Reserve.
Komm, bring mir mal die Dings,
die Unterlegscheiben
dort unten.
Tscharners sind happy.
Sie haben einen Besichtigungstermin
für ihr Traumhaus in Aussicht.
Nein, dort sind ja noch Löcher.
Je schneller sie umziehen,
desto schneller können sie
das Mobile Home vermieten.
Von unserem Ersparten zu leben,
ist nicht die Idee.
Nach ein paar Monaten
ist es schon nötig,
dass wieder mal
etwas Geld reinkommt.
Das Ziel wäre,
dass das Mobile Home
übers Jahr hinweg gesehen
zu 60-70 % ausgelastet ist,
damit das Ganze rentabel ist.
Habe ich es richtig gemacht?
- Nein.- Nein?
Der Reissverschluss ist unten.
* Mario lacht. *
Für mich ist das okay.
Ähm ...
Du kannst den Stoff entfernen,
dann klebt es.
Das Mobile Home
will die gelernte Coiffeuse
im Ranch-House-Style dekorieren.
Doch noch stehen
grundlegende Reparaturen an.
Igitt.
Mhm.
Dort unten ist es auch nass.
Ja, ich muss die Dichtung ersetzen.
- Ja.
Kein einziger Wasserhahn und
kein einziger Ablauf sind dicht.
Das Wasser tropft
da unten ins Kästchen.
Das konnten wir
noch nicht reparieren.
Vorhin sah ich,
dass wieder alles nass ist.
Diese Dinge
sollte man eigentlich reparieren,
bevor man die Küche benutzt.
Wenn vergessen geht,
dass dort Wasser runtertropft,
geht das Holz kaputt.
Dann beginnt es rasch zu faulen.
Ich mag es nicht,
zwischen Stuhl und Bank zu sein.
Ich möchte mich hier
schon wohlfühlen können.
Das ist zurzeit nicht der Fall,
weil ...
... man sich um alles
gleichzeitig kümmern müsste.
Langsam habe ich auch
ein bisschen ein schlechtes Gewissen
gegenüber den Kindern,
weil sie auch stark gefordert sind.
Das trübt meine Stimmung
ein bisschen,
weil ich mich schlecht fühle,
dass es für die Kinder
zurzeit auch sehr stressig ist.
Mallorca ist der Sehnsuchtsort
vieler Europäer:
Anfang März jedoch zeigt sich
die Insel von ihrer trüben Seite.
Das schlägt auf die Stimmung.
Mir geht vieles durch den Kopf.
Ich hoffe, dass alles gut klappt
und alles gut wird.
Ich hoffe, dass meine Ängste
etwas kleiner werden.
Mir geht so vieles durch den Kopf,
was alles geschehen könnte.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
ein finanzieller Druck vorhanden.
Ich hoffe,
dass die Rechnung aufgeht,
dass wir bis zum Saisonstart
fertig werden und starten können,
damit wieder Geld reinkommt.
Es ist zwar ein bestehender Betrieb,
den es schon lange gibt
und der schon mehr als 20 Saisons
hinter sich hat -
es ist nichts komplett Neues -,
aber man hat trotzdem
gewisse Ängste und Sorgen.
Es ist Otmar,
der die ganze Verantwortung trägt.
Er hat alles
in diesen Traum gesteckt.
Als Perfektionist setzt er sich
schnell selbst unter Druck,
weiss aber auch, was es heisst,
einen Gastrobetrieb zu leiten.
Während 15 Jahren
hat er ein eigenes Restaurant
im Luzernischen geführt.
Ihr Lokal soll dereinst
hell und luftig werden.
Keine dunklen Deckenbalken mehr.
Holz schleifen und streichen - für
Gabor wieder eine völlig neue Arbeit.
Der Ungar war Krankenpfleger,
Hotelangestellter
und später in der Schweiz
im Verkauf tätig.
Guten Tag. Hola.
Alles neu?
- Ja, wir renovieren.
Prima.
- Ja.
Es ist viel Arbeit.
Wann ist die Eröffnung?
- Wir öffnen am 17. März.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Gleichfalls.- Danke.
Für Corinna
bricht die letzte Saison an.
Sie ist noch immer stark
mit dem Lokal verbunden.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt passt.
Ne.
Man wird irgendwie zu einer Familie.
Deshalb wollte ich das Lokal
unbedingt an jemanden übergeben,
der die Mitarbeiter übernimmt
und es mit Herzblut weiterführt.
Es ist irgendwie
schon mein kleines Baby -
ein sehr, sehr arbeitsintensives,
ein kleines Monster.
So schaffe ich das nicht.
- Du musst höher hinauf.
Aber oben habe ich Angst.
Schau ...
So geht es.
- Aber du musst weiter weg.
Ja, aber ... Du verstehst nicht,
dass ich oben Angst habe.
Kannst du das halten? Es ist besser,
es von Hand zu machen.
Zu zweit geht alles besser.
Und die Renovationsarbeiten
locken Neugierige an.
(Mann) Seid ihr schon fleissig?
- Ja.
Ich bin dieses Jahr raus und
Gabor und Otmar übernehmen. - Hi.
Das ist Markus,
auch einer unserer Stammgäste.
Gabor.
- Markus. Hallo.
(Corinna)
Er brachte Düsseldorfer Korn mit.
Nicht nur Korn, auch Bier
hat der Stammgast mitgebracht.
Auf uns alle.
Ja, auf die Saison 2023.
- Ja, zum Wohl.
Und auf eine rechtzeitige Eröffnung.
- Ja.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
In Sopchoppy, mitten im Wald,
steht Tscharners Traumhaus.
Noch in der Schweiz
haben sie es im Internet entdeckt.
Hi.
- Hey.
Nach einer virtuellen Besichtigung
haben sie einen Reservationsvertrag
unterzeichnet.
Heute nun der Realitätscheck.
Gross.
120-jährig ist das Haus.
Schau, ein Cheminée, wie zu Hause.
Achtung, hier ist ein Möbelstück.
Wow, und so schöne, hohe Räume.
Ah, ja.
- That's good.
Cool.
Nebst Esszimmer, Bibliothek und Stube
gibt es sieben Schlafzimmer.
Wenigstens gibt es einen Icemaker.
Hör auf.
Das ist cool. Das braucht man.
- Ja, ich weiss, das braucht man.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Der Boden ist schon
überall sehr schräg, was?
* Melanie lacht. *
Das ist einfach schräg.
Also, das ist ...
* Melanie lacht. *
Und hier hinten noch ein Bett.
Ja, es ist ...
Es ist total speziell.
- Mhm.
Im oberen Stockwerk
müsste man alles rausreissen
und die Räume alle neu einteilen.
Es ist furchtbar.
Oder man findet sich
vorübergehend damit ab.
* Sie lacht. *
Alles total knapp.
Der Wahnsinn.
- Uh!
A crazy house.
(Kind) It's a big house.
- It's a big house.
Ein riesiges Haus
mit 380 m2 Wohnfläche.
Das sind wirklich
schöne Schlafzimmer.
Es ist kalt hier drin.
- Das ist logisch.
Wie im Saloon.
Wow!
Schau mal, das ist ...
- Wow!
The old carpet.
- Nicht reingehen.
It's too cold.
* Mario lacht. *
Hier draussen
ist es wärmer als drinnen.
Dazu gehört ein grosszügiges Gelände
mit einem verwunschenen Garten.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Eine Wasserleiche.
- (Lachend) What?
Es gibt positive
und negative Aspekte.
Die positiven Aspekte sind,
dass es sich genau in dem Dorf
befindet, in dem wir wohnen wollen,
dass es genau das Grundstück ist,
das wir immer wollten,
und dass es ein so grosses Haus ist.
Ich wollte immer
ein doppelstöckiges Haus.
Das ist sehr schwierig zu finden.
Die Amis bauen immer ebenerdig.
Wir werden nochmals
kurz darüber nachdenken,
aber die Entscheidung
ist eigentlich schon gefallen.
Wir möchten es unbedingt haben.
- Nicht wahr?
Mehr Freiraum, Abgeschiedenheit
und gemeinsam etwas aufbauen -
dafür sind
die ehemalige Immobilienmaklerin
und der Eventmanager ausgewandert.
Auf Island haben sie
den Flecken Welt dafür gefunden.
Bald schon werden sie ihre Ferien-
Logde um drei Tiny-Häuser erweitern.
Warte, jetzt sind es 7 m.
Soll ich etwas nach unten gehen?
- Das ist zu weit. 7,55 m.
7,55 m - das wäre hier.
Ich würde
noch etwas nach oben gehen.
Ja, einfach so, dass ...
Der kommt ja
noch etwas weiter nach vorn.- Ja.
Das schliesst die Terrasse mit ein.
- Okay.
Wenn man auf der Terrasse sitzt,
wäre es bei dir okay.
Ja, so ist es okay.
- So?
Ja.
- Warte kurz. Nicht ziehen.
Dann geht es etwa bis hier.
Dann wäre hier noch der Pfad.
Es ist etwas knapp, nicht wahr?
- 0,5 m rüber, würde ich sagen.
So.
Sie schlagen die Eckpfeiler
des ersten Häuschens ein.
Es geht ja nur darum,
mal einen Überblick zu haben,
wo sie ungefähr stehen würden.
Es muss erst dann genau sein,
wenn die Fundamente gebaut werden.
Dann muss es wirklich stimmen.
So.
Das Baugespann ist erstellt -
auf Isländisch.
Wenn man hier raufgeht,
öffnet man die Tür, geht rein
und hält sich hier
am Weihnachtsbaum fest.
* Isabelle lacht. *
Hier wäre der Ofen.
Hier würde man sich
vors Fenster setzen.
Ja, dann kann man ...
- Etwa so.
* Rockige Klänge *
Oh, schau. Ui, ui, ui!
Jetzt gibt es eine Flugshow.
Offroad-Fahren
ist in Island verboten.
Nur den Landbesitzern
wird es zugestanden.
Am See eine Art Grillhütte.
Hereinspaziert.
Das sind eigene Rentierfelle.
Schaf- und Rentierfelle.
Das sind Schaffelle.
- Ja.
In diesem Fall
ist das auch ein Schaffell.
Ich bin ein bisschen ein Pyromane.
Ich mache gern Feuer.
Deshalb ist eine Feuerstelle super.
Die Idee ist ja,
dass wir hier unten
einen Hotpot hinstellen,
der freie Seesicht bietet.
Dann kann man an unserem Strand
baden - in warmem Wasser.
Die 415 ha Land und ein Stück
des Sees haben etwa so viel gekostet
wie in der Schweiz ein Häuschen
mit einem Stück Garten.
Ihr nächster Nachbar
lebt gut 1 km weit entfernt.
Der Wald gehört auch uns.
Das Grundstück reicht
bis ganz dort nach oben,
wo man die Schneekette sieht,
bis zur Krete,
und dann geht es noch hinten runter.
Ja, wir haben noch gar nicht
das ganze Grundstück gesehen.
Worauf ich mich extrem freue, ist,
mit einem Islandpferd zum ersten Mal
unsere ganzen Ländereien abzureiten.
Darauf freue ich mich extrem.
* Sanfte, verträumte Klänge *
Ich hatte schon ein bisschen
den Wunsch, einsam zu leben.
Das Einzige, was ich mir
nicht unbedingt wünschte, war,
das alleine zu machen.
Ich wünschte mir eine Partnerin,
die das mitmacht.
Mit Isa ging das perfekt auf.
Man braucht eine starke Hand
an seiner Seite, die mitzieht.
Alleine ist das nicht machbar -
für mich.
Danke.
Gern geschehen.
Jetzt fällt dir dann
vor Kälte die Nase ab.
Die Sonne strahlt zum Saisonstart.
Mallorca putzt sich heraus.
* Entspannte Musik *
Die Auswanderer
haben ganze Arbeit geleistet.
Die Terrasse ist nun hell und weiss,
die Wände im Innern gestrichen.
Nur im Keller herrscht noch Chaos.
Achtung!
- Ja, ich habe es nicht gesehen.
In zwei Tagen ist Eröffnung.
Das Gerümpellager,
das wir noch räumen müssen.
Aber dafür
haben wir noch keine Zeit.
Wir stellen einfach mal
alles hier unten hin.
Es wäre schön gewesen, wenn man
vorgängig etwas hätte aufräumen
und die nicht mehr benötigten Dinge
hätte entsorgen können.
Hier hinten
wollen wir mal ein Büro einrichten,
aber das ist noch nicht möglich.
Das nervt.
Also, hier zwei.
Oder fangen wir hinten an?
- Ja.
Als Gastronom muss man flexibel sein
und eigentlich alles können.
Man muss überall mitarbeiten
und auch handwerklich
geschickt sein.
Ich bin froh, dass mir das
in die Wiege gelegt wurde,
dass ich nicht zwei linke Hände habe
und anpacken kann.
Mein Papa war ...
... ein leidenschaftlicher Koch.
Er hat mir
viel mit auf den Weg gegeben.
Der Vater war für Otmar
immer eine wichtige Stütze.
Wenige Wochen vor Otmars Auswanderung
ist er verstorben.
Er fehlt mir sehr.
* Muntere Musik *
(Frau) Hallo.
Glücklich ist, wer Freunde hat.
Gabrielle Blättler
war einst Gabors Chefin.
Zusammen mit ihrem Partner
ist sie aus der Schweiz angereist.
Sie wollen die beiden
bei der Eröffnung unterstützen.
* Gabrielle lacht. *
Es ist super.
Ich staunte v.a. über die Lampen.
Wenn die Meeresbrise weht,
bewegen sich alle.
Dann meint man,
man sei ein bisschen betrunken.
Otmar ist einer,
der Leute motivieren kann.
Maryam und Adina sind
freiwillig hier, um uns zu helfen.
Adina kellnert
schon seit Jahren im Restaurant.
Auch Maryam, der Koch,
hilft während der Ferien.
Das Gute ist:
Auch er ist handwerklich begabt.
Mit der Maschine?
Von Maryam habe ich viel gelernt.
So was habe ich
noch nie in meinem Leben gemacht.
Alle geben ihr Bestes.
V.a. Otmar sieht jeden Fleck.
* Sie lacht. *
Er sieht alles.
Das ist ... Jetzt brauche ich noch
eine Leiter, um hier hochzusteigen.
Hier ist Wasser, Gabrielle.
Hast du noch eine Leiter
oder etwas Ähnliches für mich?
Willst du einen Stuhl benutzen?
Die Leiter wird vorn gebraucht.
Oder ist das zu gefährlich?
Keine Ahnung, das siehst du dann.
- Nein, bitte nicht runterfallen.
Auch das Bedienen
einer richtigen Kolbenmaschine
muss noch gelernt sein.
Oh mein Gott!
* Abwartende Klänge *
Also, das ist ein Kaffee.
Oh, ja.
Aber nur so wenig?
Also ...
* Angeekeltes Geräusch *
Der ist nicht gut.
Ich mache jetzt ...
Ein Kaffee aus der Kapselmaschine
genügt - vorerst.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Das ist für Maryam.
Zwei Tage noch,
und dann muss alles funktionieren.
Schön ist es hier, eine schöne Ecke
habt ihr euch ausgesucht.- Danke.
Wir geben unser Bestes.
Uns unterstützen
bestehende Mitarbeiter
und die Gäste
kommen gewiss auch wegen ihnen.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Ich gebe mich immer so, wie ich bin.
Ich bin sehr offen und lustig.
In der Schweiz
mochten das die Leute sehr.
Das wurde mir von allen bestätigt.
Ich sei sehr offen
und ein bisschen ein Spinner.
Das kommt gut an bei den Kunden.
- Das Gabörchen.
Am Anfang fragten schon
einige Leute, wann eröffnet wird,
weil sie das Schild
zuerst nicht sahen.
Huhu!
- Wo wollen wir uns einrichten?
Vom Mobile Home der Familie Tscharner
ans Meer ist es ein Katzensprung.
Gleich hier.
Das ist ein schönes Plätzchen.
Breitet ihr euch hier aus?
- Ja.
The Forgotten Coast:
Vor neun Jahren haben Melanie und
Mario die Küste für sich entdeckt.
Wann immer sie konnten, kehrten sie
während der Ferien hierher zurück.
Der Walensee ist jeweils kälter.
Mach dich nicht ganz nass,
Lily Rose.
Wir können es
immer noch nicht richtig glauben.
Jetzt wohnen wir am Meer.
Es ist noch nicht ganz real.- Mhm.
Wahnsinn.
Vielleicht fahren wir bald
mit unserem eigenen Boot
zu der Insel dort.
Und es gibt einen Grund, zu feiern:
Sie haben sich entschieden.
Mario und Melanie
kaufen das Haus in Sopchoppy.
Thank you. Wow!
Wow! Wahnsinnig hoch.
Mhm.
Stossen wir auf unser neues Haus an?
Prost.
- Prost.
Prost. Und du, Schätzchen?
- Prost.- Prost.
Ein solches Haus
findet man nicht alle Tage.
Auch hier im Land
der unbegrenzten Möglichkeiten
gibt es nicht viele davon
auf dem Markt -
und dann noch zu diesem Preis.
Das war wirklich
eine einmalige Gelegenheit.
Ich glaube,
es ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Ich glaube ...
Es fühlt sich wirklich richtig an.
Wir wären blöd, wenn wir uns das
durch die Lappen gingen liessen.
Schau, der schöne Sonnenuntergang.
Schau, wie schön das aussieht.
- Wow!- Mama!
Lily Rose hat etwas gemacht.
Und in der nächsten Folge
von "Auf und davon":
Kurz vor Eröffnung ist
die Stimmung auf Mallorca angespannt.
Das ist jetzt passiert.
Jetzt hat er sich wehgetan.
Jetzt haben wir geöffnet.
Die Gäste können kommen.
Einmal komplett öffnen.
- Gabor muss sich bewähren.
Als ich die Tabletts hielt,
hat meine Hand gezittert.
Familie Tscharner ist umgezogen.
Noch immer ist es kalt,
und die Heizung
ihres Traumhauses macht Probleme.
Da läuft nix mehr.
Sie renovieren ihr Mobile Home.
* Mario lacht. *
Und Lily Roses erster Schultag
endet anders als gedacht.
Sie ist in der 2.,
nicht in der 1. Klasse.
Vorbei mit der idyllischen Ruhe
auf Island.
Der Bau der Tiny-Häuser beginnt.
Gleichzeitig empfangen sie Gäste.
So ...
Das wäre euer Zimmer.
Und es gilt, die Schweizer
Zimmerleute zu verpflegen.
Gleichzeitig zu bauen,
zu putzen, zu arbeiten
und nebst den Arbeitern
noch richtige Gäste zu haben,
ist schon relativ viel.
# U sie stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüm meh hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024
# Uf u dervo, yeah.